I'm curious about it's in my head 24/7
it's not announced I continue I don't I
don't think about nothing else and
that's it I'm just curious everything I
do in my life is is related to this I
don't do nothing else if it's not got to
do it fine
I mean and that that is why and I mean
to be true that's all you've got to do a
show I'm in phenomenal shape in body and
mind to me what's unhealthy is living
and on a healthy life to me what's
unhealthy is getting up and going
through the same day every day I like
9:00 to 5:00 in an office or in a you
know that bats unhealthy that beats your
mind I don't I don't work I what about
love what I do and that's why I'm doing
what I love and I mean that's why that's
why it's become a career for me because
I love it I love what I do so I don't
think it's unhealthy I I feel good in my
mind I mean it's it's my it's my life
you stare at your past and you'll end up
staying there it's okay to look back and
admire it but you carry on I'm not in
the business of staring in a back alley
I mean I'm getting lost back there
people say a loss can make a break a
fighter but trust me a win can also make
a break a fire because they get
comfortable with it with a win people
can get comfortable with it with a win
and slack off their slack off on the
train and slack off on the diet they've
won one they're winners now that's not
me and you sleep on a win and you'll
wake up with a loss so I just carry on
keep doing what I'm doing it's it's
perfect
continue on this path the freight train
straight to the top you just watch -
amazing clips from Conor McGregor take
the next three minutes to sit quietly I
think about how to apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]